the wilderness and you can only pick one
of us to be with you to help you get
through the wilderness I'm Anne I think
they're gonna be boring and there's each
other but like what are you what who
would you pick I picked Blake and I
would kill him and take the vodka it's
back pocket cuz I Got News for you you
see his Starbucks mug on the voice right
y'all see I ain't coffee so yeah how
y'all do this job without drinking
drinking little red wine for Johnson uh
oh I can't I went I'm already crazy yeah
yeah wait who would you pick on an
island like if he our wilderness we got
dropped in the wilderness and you just
had to pick one of us I feel like Blake
because he ranch like I feel like he
would know a lot of outdoorsy things
that would get us through life but also
make a good round Kayla you can't even
beat me on your own show it's true I
remember the first time I went to
Oklahoma with my family we are like from
Anaheim we'd never seen even trees
before so we were like wow this is like
crazy and we're like driving and Blake's
in his truck and there's a tree that had
like been blown down on the road and
like it's out and he's like all right he
gets in the back of the truck he's like
Shane saw a big chain and he he wrapped
it around the tree and like pull like my
whole family's like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he pulls out a chainsaw Lake was so
early on in the show he'd be in LA he's
such an Oklahoman I mean he really is
like he was miserable here before I
started fornicating with our before
Blake does be feared when wind does make
him happier when we were in LA would be
a mission to try and find something for
the cowboy to do because he was such a
fish out of water in LA and so we had
the idea we won one day we went to where
he would I thought be comfortable and I
took him to an old to a Bass Pro Shop
and I walking around with Blake Shelton
at a Bass Pro Shop was like walking
around with Jesus Christ at the Vatican
like his people are there he was very at
home I'm comfortable here I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this